we are indeed with Emily from The World
Chess Hall of Fame you are one of the
curators at the world just Hall of Fame
tell us Emily what do you guys do there
kinds of things related to the history
of Chess just earlier this week we had
Hall of Fame inductions so we have
Eugene Torre in town as he's been on the
commentary earlier this week and we also
had Jim Tarzan here and they were both
here for the opening ceremony and were
inducted into the world in U.S chess
Halls of Fame oh sorry we also have a
big exhibition up right now for the 50th
anniversary of the 1972 World Chess
Championship match and that is a great
one actually uh the 1972 match between
Bobby Fisher and spaski tell us a bit
about that yeah so 50 years ago the most
famous World Chess Championship ever
happened and it has a big impact both
for us here in the U.S on American chess
but also at the hall of fame because it
inspired the chess campus co-founder Rex
sinkfield to really take up the game so
we have artifacts from Bobby and borsa's
childhoods all the way up through their
later years and I know you guys have
some uh artifacts that you recently got
can you tell us a bit about that as well
yeah so we have some special artifacts
on loan to us that have to do with Boris
basky's career but we also have some
really fantastic new donations that are
drawings and watercolors of the match
that were done by the artist LeRoy
Neiman for the match he was on the
television show Wide World of Sports and
he showed off what was going on and so
those are really special additions to
our collection I have to say that just
an incredible exhibit and if you are
here in St Louis and if you have time to
go visit the workshest Hall of Fame you
should definitely do that Yasser
Anastasia you guys want to join the
numbers I absolutely Emily you said that
this was the most celebrated match in
world championship history I want to
take you to task on that one uh 1886 St
Louis hosted the first world
championship and it got International
press
that's true that's true we have a deep
rich history of Chess right here in St
Louis that's continuing today Emily
thank you very much for everything that
you guys are doing there at the World
Chess Hall of Fame thank you for having
me thank you Emily absolutely and indeed
uh the World Chess Hall of Fame just
across the street really is amazing very
impressive I know that